i should be working on at least two
other videos right now
but news of this new standalone game has
had the old tinfoil hat working overtime
i need to get this out of my system
before i can move on
so bear with me while i take you through
one of the many ideas i've had around
what this game could be based around
using the small amount of information
we've received so far
this is following on from what i
mentioned in the last video about the
similarities the image showed to ann
arbor
in michigan ann arbor is a small city in
the midwestern state of michigan
home to the university of michigan it is
known for its large-scale research and
development programs
in the division story ann arbor has one
of the last research facilities that is
still operational on the midwestern side
of the united states
due to its low population density the
city didn't appear to be hit as hard as
other major centres by the dollar flu
and because of the college town's remote
location access to laboratories and
technology
the jtf quickly locked down the area
while scientists worked on a cure
it's more than likely that this is where
jessica candle ended up after the events
of the division one
those of you who have been following
this channel for a while will be more
than aware of april kelleher's story
i've talked about her a lot and as my
wife keeps reminding me i still haven't
finished the final breakdown of the
broken door novel portion of this story
i might get onto that soon if anything
just to stop her from nagging me
but for those of you unfamiliar with
this story or needing a quick recap
i'll try and sum that up now but i have
a bunch of videos on her in the
description
or better again i highly recommend
getting the new york collapse and broken
dawn books
she has by far the best story in the
division world and it really gives you
an idea of what it was like on the
streets of new york and rural america
during this time
april's story begins in new york city
where she lives with her husband
the same day that the manhattan
quarantine was put in place she went to
visit her husband at work
where she had to watch him from a
distance be gunned down in front of his
office
by unknown men dressed in black
stuck on the island because of the
quarantine she roamed the area
not just trying to survive but looking
for clues on why her husband was
murdered
writing in a book she was gifted by her
husband called new york collapse
a survival guide to urban catastrophe
she wrote down her thoughts
and experiences april talks about the
state of the city
and her confusion around his death she
also describes a number of different
events where she had come into contact
with rikers
in both division and rogue agents
including aaron kina
over time she witnessed a number of
friends succumbed to the events that
occurred
as well as the virus she goes into
detail around the time that she too
contracted an illness that resembled the
dole flow
and survived eventually april finds
someone deep inside the dark zone by the
name of merch
who knows of her husband and what he was
working on
he was responsible for his part in the
development of a class of vaccines
known as broad-spectrum antivirals a
type of vaccine that could help fight
against all strains of the green poison
this work led him to being killed for
his involvement by an unknown
organization
merch tells april that there is a lab in
ann arbor that is currently working on
the antivirals
and had worked with her husband april
decides to make her way to the lab
to take a look at what he'd given his
life for
outside of the major cities april runs
into a number of different groups
mostly just people doing their best to
survive during this time
but she certainly ran into a few who
were taking advantage of the current
situation
and in one such situation just outside
ann arbor
she was rescued by shd agent ike ronson
from a group of criminals
when they made it to the city they
decided to rest before visiting the labs
the next day
camping out on a rooftop cafe they were
met by another shd agent
aurelio diaz
the next day the three of them visited
the research facility and talked with
the head researcher
who confirms that they have in fact been
working on the broad spectrum antivirals
it was during this time that diaz
received a call it was revealed that
ronson has been working as a double
agent
for an organization called the black
tusk
ronson was a rogue agent
although diaz managed to subdue ronson
it was too late
the cavalry was on its way a full-scale
black tusk attack was fast approaching
the compound
april and diaz leave him behind and
managed to escape through a forest
nearby
and this is where they're part ways
april heads off to washington dc
to tell them of what she had witnessed
while diaz decided to head east
and do what he could to put a stop to
this new invading force
so from this what do we have civilians
doctors scientists laboratory workers
black tusk agents rogues anti-virals
and a free-to-play game now let's be
fair free to play could mean any number
of things
but if it is in fact based in michigan
we have a few decent factors here that
could make up a pretty fun game
with a solid story to back it up i need
to state right now that i've had
absolutely no contact with the
developers working on this or anyone
involved
actually now that i think of it i don't
think i've ever had a response from them
oh well what i'm trying to say is i have
absolutely no inside knowledge of what's
going on
and that what i'm about to talk about is
simply my own ideas around what this
game could be
with that out of the way picture this a
dark zone
pve vp survival last stand zone control
hybrid
hear me out we have a map of ann arbor
including some of the rural space around
it and although there is likely to be a
number of smaller activities involved
throughout
the overarching mission is to gain
control of the city
there is the shd agents the black tusk
potentially the ai faction
and the rogues they are all fighting for
control of ann arbor
with the main research facility being
located in the middle of the map i
probably need to bring up some visuals
to better explain the craziness going on
in my head
apologies i'm not hugely familiar with
ann arbor's district zoning
this was just something i quickly threw
together
in the center we have the research
facility civilians are scattered
throughout
as you'd expect it's a city after all
each of the factions have their own home
location or starting point
an area that cannot be captured by the
opposing factions
the area outside of these home locations
are also generally assumed to be kept
under control
due to the faction influence or fear and
have support from the civilians located
there
making it harder to lose or be captured
by opposing factions
as factions get further away from their
home locations it gets more difficult
and requires more effort and
coordination to capture districts
also district control can be lost not
just by other factions
but due to the civilian occupation not
being kept happy
this could be a short round-based battle
or a long-term beast
where it takes considerable time to
capture a district with a potential
ladder reset every now and then
this would be a game type where the pvp
and pve
are just as important yes you're coming
up against opposing human players on one
front
but equally there is an npc battle going
on over the other side
that needs to be kept in check plus
there are civilians in each district
that need to be kept happy
or they will revolt the centre of the
map holds the overall goal
and although you can run into any
uncontrolled district freely when not
under the control of your faction
the people here will be considerably
more hostile towards you
on the other side when traveling through
an area under your faction's control
there will be support from the civilians
and militia groups as well as restocks
and potentially vendors however gaining
control of the regions around the
central research facility
will gain weapons and equipment and
glory points for your faction
at a greater rate than what could be
acquired anywhere else on the map
this game mode would need to include a
large number of players to do it justice
not just the usual 8 or 12 players
or maybe heartlands would just be
another bloody battle royale
so this is all fairly unlikely to happen
but i still think it would be pretty
cool
it's certainly something i'd be keen on
playing well done if you've made it this
far listening to me neteron about my
random ideas
my wife was getting sick of hearing
about them so i had to tell someone
i have so many more but i think i'll
have to try and restrain from talking
about them too much
like my ideas around the mobile game and
how they could use augmented reality to
create something a little more
interesting
than most of us are probably imagining
they'll produce
i should totally get into game
development if i actually had any
tangible skills to bring to the table
okay i'm rambling again anyway thank you
very much for watching
and i'll catch in the next one cheers
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you